hey gq i'm olivia rodrigo and today i'm
going undercover on the internet
it's actually me
[Music]
let's check twitter
at olivia rodrigo if you had to pick one
song from the sour album that best
represents you which one would you pick
and why oh my god that's so difficult i
really love driver's license it's still
my favorite song i've ever written and i
feel like it was the first song i ever
wrote that really like captured how i
felt and was really representative of
who i was as a person so that'll always
you know stay in my heart next
wait how did olivia rodrigo get her
driver's license if she can't parallel
park
great question very observant
actually nowadays in california when you
take your driver's test you do not need
to parallel park you just need to like
go up against a curb and like like back
up like a yard or two so um yeah i i
passed with flying colors
i have a question for you at olivia
rodrigo or had the other nine songs that
didn't make it onto the album bff would
like an answer oh my gosh
i don't know they're in a hard drive
somewhere on my producer's computer
never to see the light of day
replied
now onto cora what's olivia rodrigo's
aesthetic called
gosh i would call it i'm 18 and have
truly no sense of personal style yet but
i'd try and stuff that's colorful and
fun and comfortable and young
next one is is olivia rodrigo currently
living with her parents technically i'm
not living with my parents i got my
first big girl apartment a month or two
ago and it's very exciting but my
parents come and stay with me all the
time and i go stay with them all the
time so
i don't know i don't know if i'm
technically living alone but i say i am
replied
did olivia rodrigo take singing lessons
olivia rodrigo did take singing lessons
for a while since she was literally like
five years old
all right let's see some youtube
comments
how did she go from bizaardvark to this
oh gosh
um
i don't know i don't know i just grew up
wrote my songs and
did my thing i don't know that music
video was so much fun to film it was one
of my favorite days on set in my life
petra who directed it is one of my like
creative muses and so it was really fun
to work with her on that we got to like
light stuff on fire and like flood stuff
so it was it was a great day
why are her lives always a key down i'm
getting even curious because sometimes
in the studio when you're recording
stuff it feels more intense to have it
like up a little bit and then when it
comes time to singing it live you kind
of get like scared to sing it really
high so you just like bring it down the
key
next
olivia is incredible the control she has
over her voice is insane and so
beautiful also at 0.48 it looks like she
has a necklace with i still love you
engraved on it or is it just me love her
so much
yes i did wear a necklace that said i
still love you when i performed driver's
license on snl and it's a locket too but
i won't tell you what i put in it that's
for me to know
replied
wikipedia
acting career rodrigo first appeared on
screen in an old navy commercial yes
that was my first ever job i was in like
first grade or something and the only
thing i had to do is like turn around
and go
and like i did that like all day and i
remember being like mom i don't know if
i'm cut out for this like this is a lot
of work and here i am
posted
reddit
scary
favorite crime woo congratulations to
olivia i hope she enjoys graduation is
she a fan of rick and morty i wonder
what her plans are next after this you
know what i haven't watched an episode
of rick and morty i feel like i should i
have a lot of friends who are obsessed
with it so maybe that's
on the agenda replied
back to twitter at olivia rodrigo how do
you think of song names i know in the
short film you said you just had to be
alone but is there more to that yeah i
mean i guess like just song names and
song concepts and song lyrics and
everything just sort of come randomly
throughout the day in your normal life
i'll usually just write them down and
then the trick is is like having the
work ethic and focus to flush it out and
really make it into something you don't
have to be alone to write a song i wrote
many songs on set so
olivia rodrigo showed up to fans houses
and gave them merch and asked them to
prom i'm obsessed with her that's insane
oh i'm obsessed with you i'm doing a
concert film that's prom themed because
i never went to prom so we were like oh
it'd be perfect we can do like a little
makeup for your prom i wanted to invite
a couple of people to premiere and i
wanted to have some prom dates yeah it's
gonna be fun replied at oliver rodrigo
how does it feel that an icon like at
kelly clarkson covered your song
congratulations oh
so sweet yeah i love kelly clarkson and
i grew up listening to her and so it was
really surreal to see harrison driver's
license
so special
posted
instagram
[Music]
it's a picture of me in
this cap and gown um essentially it was
not my cap and gown i actually stole
this from my best friend iris
i didn't order a cap and gown because
i'm homeschooled and we like don't have
a graduation so i just stole her and
took a picture in it and luke asks you
were in high school this whole time
yes i was
just graduated feeling so stoked about
it next quora
how does olivia rodrigo get out of a bad
date um
i am
a little bit of a people pleaser i'm
really working on it but if there's like
a bad date situation going on i just
like do the whole thing and like wait
until they drop me off because i don't
want to like make it uncomfortable and
be like i want to leave
but i haven't had too many bad days in
my life luckily posted
is it livi rodriguez life perfect um
no olivia rodrigo's life is far from
perfect i
have many blessings in my life but my
life is definitely not perfect where is
olivia's acting career added to oh my
god
um
your guess is as good as mine i don't
know we'll see we'll see what the future
brings
thank you guys for all of your questions
that's it i am signing off the internet
peace